every once in a while you get a craving
that you simply can't control you
absolutely positively need to watch a
number of batman movies if you feel like
having a batman movie marathon right now
and don't have the time or inclination
to track down a bunch of bat movies from
different sources then netflix is your
friend the streaming service carries a
nice variety of batman films and they're
different enough that you won't ever get
bored in fact you'll be able to enjoy a
whole bunch of different takes on both
the cape's crusader himself as well as
his rogues gallery from academy
award-winning efforts to delightfully
goofy animated creations
omg it's batman
what's up to you is not only which of
these titles you decide to watch but the
order in which you choose to view them
thankfully we've got some ideas about
how to pull off a gotham city themed
movie marathon with style but first
here's every batman movie you can binge
watch on netflix right now there are
currently 4 batman films on netflix
which is scientifically the optimal
number for a proper movie marathon in
case that isn't exciting enough two of
the batman movies present on the
streaming service right now are batman
begins and the dark knight the first two
instalments in director christopher
nolan's acclaimed dark knight trilogy
together the pair of live-action batman
movies give you the chance to spend a
good few hours with christian bale's
grounded growly version of the bat in
addition to bale's version of bruce
wayne batman begins and the dark knight
also features several truly memorable
takes on some of the cape's crusaders
most iconic villains including liam
neeson's raz al ghul killian murphy's
scarecrow aaron eckhart harvey dent aka
two face and of course heath ledger's
joker you look nervous
is it the scars
you want to know how i got them
the supporting casts of both films are
also undeniably stellar with reliable
heavy hitters like gary oldman michael
kane tom wilkinson and morgan freeman
all showing up at various points as
important and notable dc comics
characters unfortunately the third
installment in nolan's batman trilogy
2012's the dark knight rises is not on
netflix right now if you're set on
sitting down and marathoning the entire
dark knight trilogy that means you'll
have to look elsewhere to watch its
final chapter the good news is that even
without the dark knight rises both the
batman begins and the dark knight offer
more than enough of the thrills
necessary to make one netflix streaming
session feel worthwhile there are two
other batman movies available to stream
on netflix right now batman the killing
joke and the 22 minute lego dc comics
batman beleaguered the former title pits
kevin conroy's batman against mark
hamill's joker in an adaptation of alan
moore and brian bollins a classic
graphic novel batman be leaguered
meanwhile caesar troy baker voiced lego
batman and the nascent justice league
embark on a global battle against a
truly surprising villain the two
animated titles could not be more
different from each other or from the
christopher nolan directed live-action
films that netflix also has to offer
fortunately that means there's room for
you to toss some real variety into your
batman-centric streaming plans depending
on how you want to approach your bat
marathon you could start with something
serious like batman begins and then
follow that film up with its actual
sequel the dark knight from there you
can let heath ledger's fan favorite
joker act as your gateway to true chaos
as you slide from the comparatively
realistic nolan verse to the even darker
world and more sinister plot of the
killing joke finally as you're winding
down from the non-stop chaos of the
killing joke and the dark knight there's
no better way to step out of the
darkness of those films and back into
the light than by turning on batman
beleaguered
i lose more bad subs this way
alternatively you could start soft and
go from batman be leaguer to killing
joke and end with batman begins and the
dark knight or even sandwich the
animated films in between the two nolan
movies after all it's your movie
marathon there are no rules there's only
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]